new zealand alongside being the current
reigning champion of places that people
forget to put on maps it's also an
independent country
this independence did not occur through
one single event like that of the united
states but through a century-long
process of reform
and across this century many were fairly
sure that new zealand would become a
part of the new commonwealth of
australia
in the same way that quebec was
obviously going to be a part of canada
or how bombay was obviously going to be
part of india
yet as you'll know this never happened
but why
why isn't new zealand a part of
australia to begin we have to go back to
those ancient days of pre-australia
sometimes called the mid-19th century
at this point australia wasn't one
colony but instead six and they were as
far as the british were concerned a part
of an a-colony collective
the other two being fiji and of course
new zealand all of these colonies had
different economies different foreign
interests and different cultures which
is why at first many were opposed to
federalisation
things changed when germany started
eyeing up the region which made those in
the eight colonies pretty nervous
and when the colony of new south wales
changed its mind about federalization
the other colonies now feared being left
out and thus
it was time to build in australia for
new zealand this being cut off was less
of a problem
whilst new south wales tasmania victoria
queensland south australia and the other
one may have traded primarily with each
other
new zealand traded mostly with britain
there were other reasons for new zealand
rejecting federation too
the first was the massive distance
between itself and australia which for
reference is the same
distance between britain and morocco
another was that the drafting of the
documents for australian federation were
done by those who lived in australia
which might sound incredibly obvious but
new zealand and fiji weren't given an
opportunity to contribute much to the
discussions
and thus they were largely seen as
places that would be added to australia
as opposed to a foundational part of it
which upset many new zealanders who
wanted to be seen as equals
and this lack of consideration for new
zealand's distinction is what mostly
scuppered any chance of it being a part
of australia
you see new zealand had a long and
storied history between the island's
indigenous people the maori and the
european settlers the pakeha
and there were concerns that integration
into australia a place not highly rated
on the kindness to the people already
living their armata would mean that the
maori would again be reduced to
second-class citizens and importantly
violate the treaty of waitangi
which as a result would lead to another
war there were fair reasons to believe
this since the draft constitution
explicitly stated that the indigenous
people were to be ruled over by the
whites there and new zealand thus
demanded that this not apply to them and
that they would refuse to join unless
australia amended its constitution
which it agreed to so why wasn't this
enough well it was mostly a concern by
new zealanders about the number of
chinese and asian workers in australia
and particularly the potential that
those workers would head to new zealand
which the leaders there really didn't
want
and when australia federated in 1901 it
was these combined reasons that saw new
zealand sit it out
although there is still a clause in the
australian constitution that allows new
zealand to join whenever it wants
so the door is still open i hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching with a special thanks to my
patrons james bisonette kelly moneymaker
anthony beckett the pastry section danny
maloney rob waterhouse
moe aaron the white james castaneda
jordan longley jerry lamdin
marcus asner gustav swan john bailey
cooling castleman rasheed ali
spinning three plates filter oink oink
izzy david silverman maggie paxkowski
winston k wood spencer lightfoot robert
wetzel fortunate calf
lexi schwinn skye chappelle and marvin
cassell